[Música]
la familia real británica se congrega en
torno a la Reina Isabel segunda en
Escocia la monarca se encuentra bajo
supervisión después de que su equipo
médico expresara preocupación sobre su
estado de salud en esta emisión
actualizamos los más recientes detalles
sobre cómo se encuentra la soberana
el ejército de ucraniano asegura haber
penetrado 50 kilómetros en la línea rusa
en torno a la ciudad de harkif al
noreste del país las fuerzas de kiev
aseguran que liberaron más de 20 pueblos
y localidades en una contra ofensiva que
coincide con las visitas Sorpresa del
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Anthony blinken a la capital ucraniana
el presidente de Francia de Manuel
macron lanzó el Consejo Nacional de la
refundación un nuevo espacio creado para
mejorar la comunicación con la sociedad
civil se trata de un foro con
representantes de varios ámbitos pero en
el que no estará la oposición al
mandatario y la mayoría de los
sindicatos
nueva emisión informativa en la pantalla
de France 24 Gracias a ustedes por
continuar con nuestra señal Yo soy Juan
pupiales la noticia del día está en
Escocia con la salud de la Reina Isabel
segunda quien se encuentra bajo
supervisión después de que su equipo
médico expresara preocupación por su
estado la monarca que tiene 96 años y la
más longeva en la historia de Reino
Unido se encuentra en su residencia
vacacional de balmoral según el
comunicado divulgado por el Palacio de
buckingham hasta ese Palacio en suelo
escocés han ido llegando los miembros
más cercanos de la familia real los
últimos en hacerlo fueron los hijos de
La Reina del príncipe Andrew y el
príncipe Edward este último acompañado
de su esposa Sofía llegaron en un auto
conducido por el propio príncipe William
hijo del príncipe Carlos y primero en la
línea de sucesión y de la difunta llena
de gales precisamente Carlos y su esposa
Camila Parker fueron los primeros en
llegar al lado de la reina de acuerdo
con la cadena bbc Harry El hijo menor de
Carlos y Diana está el camino a Escocia
en el castillo de balmoral los oficiales
hacen Guardia mientras la familia real
se apresura para estar al lado de la
Reina Isabel II permanece bajo
supervisión médica en su hogar escocés
después de que los médicos expresaran
preocupación por su salud en Westminster
Londres el parlamento se tomó un momento
para expresar su apoyo a la monarca de
96 años
en nombre de toda la cámara Cuando digo
que enviamos nuestros mejores deseos a
Su Majestad la reina y que ella y la
familia real están en nuestros
pensamientos y oraciones en este momento
la Reina Isabel ha sufrido problemas de
salud desde octubre pasado
experimentando lo que sus portavoces han
llamado problemas de movilidad episódica
obligándola a reducir las apariciones
públicas
el martes la reina recibió el Primer
Ministro saliente Boris Johnson en
balmoral quien presentó su renuncia
antes de que listros asumiera como su
reemplazo al día siguiente canceló una
reunión virtual de su consejo privado
cuando sus médicos la aconsejaron
descansar trolls tuiteó su preocupación
cuando la información sobre el estado de
salud de Isabel se extendió por todo el
país desde la oposición el líder
laurista carestar hizo lo mismo este año
la soberana regente más longeva de Reino
Unido celebró 70 años en el trono el
príncipe Carlos asumirá la
responsabilidad real una vez que su
madre Isabel muera previamente
conectamos con nuestra corresponsal en
Londres Luisa Pulido quien nos entregó
más a detalles acerca del ambiente que
hay en estos momentos en el país y las
novedades en torno al palacio de
balmoral en donde permanece la Monarca
Buenas tardes poco a poco miembros del
público y los turistas que están en
Londres o en Escocia han ido acercándose
a la residencias oficiales de la familia
real especialmente en balmoral donde se
encuentra la monarca de 96 años el
castillo de Windsor que es el favorito
de la reina las afueras de Londres y
también en el Palacio de buckingham
ubicado en el centro de la capital
británica para dejar flores y mensajes
de apoyo y fuerza para la monarca que
está enfrentando problemas de movilidad
no sabemos qué tal es el estado de salud
de la Reina Isabel Porque el Palacio de
buckingham entregó detalles alarmantes
dijo que los doctores Están preocupados
por el estado de la salud de la reina
Pero no tenemos certeza exactamente Cuál
es el mal que la queja como lo
mencionabas la reina ya Está rodeada de
su familia más cercana pero también hace
poco aterrizó un avión de la Fuerza
Armada real británica en una de las
puntas de Escocia y transporta vía
terrestre hasta el castillo de balmora
lo aproximadamente una hora ya deben
estar llegando al castillo para poder
acompañar a la monarca en este momento
tan difícil no hay un nuevo parte
oficial sobre el estado de salud de la
reina sobre su evolución y solamente lo
conoceremos de manera oficial Así que
esa es la expectativa Por supuesto que
se viene el país donde hay un tipo de
tristeza y también de shock porque como
lo mencionaban ustedes hace apenas dos
días Vimos a la reina así con problemas
de movilidad utilizando un vasto para
poder sostenerse un poco más delgada que
usualmente pero sonriendo Así que ese es
la gran sorpresa y la expectativa que
gira en torno en este momento aquí en el
Reino Unido
hablamos de la guerra en Ucrania porque
el secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos llegó de manera sorpresiva aquí
es la capital ucraniana y se reunió con
el presidente de bolo divina se la encía
en una muestra de apoyo de la
administración del presidente Joe biden
se trata de la Segunda visita de blink
en asuelo ucraniano desde que comenzó la
invasión en febrero el alto funcionario
norteamericano Se comprometió con
brindar 2.000 millones de dólares en
ayuda a Ucrania y otros 18 países en
riesgo de una agresión rusa previamente
el gobierno de Estados Unidos había
aprobado un paquete de 675 millones de
dólares en armamento para kiev Bueno
más de seis meses después de la guerra
de agresión a Rusia contra Ucrania su
contraofensiva ya está en marcha y está
demostrando su eficacia eso es por
supuesto principalmente por la increíble
valentía de resistencia de los
ucranianos
eso en el campo de batalla todos los
días estamos muy contentos de haber
podido apoyar sus esfuerzos
conseguiremos haciéndolos
estas son señales muy importantes de que
los Estados Unidos de América están con
nosotros para nosotros es una garantía
de que podemos recuperar nuestros
territorios y nuestras tierras una vez
más estoy agradecido por Esta visita
mi amor
en medio de esta visita el ejército de
Chief asegura haber penetrado 50
kilómetros en la línea rusa en torno a
la ciudad clave de harkif en el noreste
del territorio las fuerzas ucranianas
dicen haber liberado 20 localidades en
una extensión de 700 kilómetros
cuadrados se cree que la mayoría de
estos avances se lograron a lo largo de
esta semana de manera sorpresiva y de
confirmarse sería un importante
retroceso para el kremlin
el desarrollo de la humanidad retrocedió
cinco años por la pandemia del Hobbit 19
y la guerra en Ucrania así lo expuso una
oficina de la ONU en su más reciente
informe el reporte señala que además de
las preocupaciones cotidianas ahora la
crisis climática las transformaciones
sociales de Gran alcance y la creciente
polarización han creado un nuevo grupo
de incertidumbres
un nuevo virus que paralizó gran parte
del mundo una crisis energética y la
interrupción del suministro de alimentos
y los efectos del cambio climático cada
vez más evidentes un nuevo grupo de
incertidumbres ha surgido por primera
vez en la historia de la humanidad según
Naciones Unidas
sí antes hemos tenido desastres antes
hemos tenido conflictos pero la
confluencia de lo que estamos afrontando
ahora es un gran revés para el
desarrollo humano el índice de
desarrollo humano del pnud que mide la
esperanza de vida los niveles de
educación y el nivel de vida descendió
durante dos años consecutivos un
retroceso sin precedentes en el progreso
humano visto en 9 de cada 10 países el
promedio de la esperanza de vida a nivel
mundial se redujo un año y medio entre
2019 y 2021 además de la perspectiva de
morir antes tener menos educación Y peor
situación económica la globalización la
polarización política y otras
transformaciones de la sociedad están
provocando un nuevo aumento del
sentimiento de inseguridad
lo más importante que tenemos que hacer
es volver a poner en el centro a las
personas y las decisiones que tomamos
Esto es lo que está en el corazón de una
creciente polarización una creciente
alienación extremismo y violencia
estamos viendo confianza entre los
ciudadanos en sus instituciones y el
gobierno
las consecuencias de la invasión rusa de
Ucrania sobre la seguridad alimentaria y
energética no se calcularon en el último
índice lo que no deja lugar a dudas de
que las perspectivas para el próximo año
son sombrías
como adelantábamos en nuestro titulares
el presidente de Francia en Manuel
macron presenta este jueves el nuevo
Consejo Nacional de la refundación un
espacio de diálogo con el que el
mandatario Busca acercarse a la sociedad
civil sin embargo ninguna facción de la
oposición hace parte de este foro en la
mayoría de los sindicatos desde París
nuestra periodística olavarría nos envió
previamente el siguiente informe
la oposición en pleno ha decidido
restarse de este Consejo Nacional de la
restauración la última idea de
democracia directa que ha tenido el
presidente Manuel macrón nació y fue
anunciada recordemos en junio Poco
después de la segunda vuelta de la
presidenciales en que fue reelecto con
dificultad y justamente al inicio de la
campaña de Cara a las elecciones
legislativas donde finalmente su partido
terminó perdiendo la mayoría absoluta
según él tras las presidenciales La
promesa era de crear una nueva forma de
hacer política se le criticaba ser
demasiado vertical y alejado del pueblo
la idea de este consejo es justamente
que se busquen consensos y que
participen en él las fuerzas vivas de la
nación políticos pero también
empresarios sindicatos alcaldes los
territorios para hacer frente a los
grandes temas de este segundo quinquenio
sin embargo por qué no ha tenido éxito
primero porque la oposición cree que el
presidente Busca hacer de este consejo
una fuerza paralela a la asamblea
nacional donde ya no tiene mayoría y
donde realmente se está ejerciendo una
fuerza de contrapeso al poder ejecutivo
pero también porque ya no le creen los
ejercicios de democracia directa al
presidente recordemos el gran debate que
viene tras la crisis de los chalecos
amarillos no sirvió para nada y luego
también la convención ciudadana del
clima y son muchas proposiciones de las
cuales solo una ínfima parte aparecieron
en la ley del clima
en Canadá terminó la persecución de tres
días contra el Último sospechoso del
apuñalamiento masivo en una reserva
indígena de saskewan en la que mataron a
10 personas Aunque la policía capturó a
mile sanderson luego el falleció en el
hospital Aparentemente por heridas que
el mismo se hizo
Canadá cierra uno de los capítulos más
oscuros de su historia reciente el
segundo de los dos sospechosos del
apuñalamiento masivo que el fin de
semana cobro 10 vidas está muerto mal
sanderson falleció luego de ser detenido
al norte del país tras una fuga de más
de tres días circulaba a más de 150
kilómetros por hora por una autopista
cuando fue finalmente alcanzado por la
policía
la policía rodeó el vehículo
confirmó que era él
lo arresto se encontró un cuchillo en la
escenario Poco después entró en
dificultad médica llamó el servicio de
emergencias
fue llevado al hospital donde lo
declararon muerto
las circunstancias concretas del
fallecimiento serán determinadas por la
autopsia su hermano demien también
dichoso de la masacre ya había sido
encontrado muerto el lunes la policía
investiga si fue asesinado por miles
pues presentaba lesiones causadas por
otra persona ambos eran los Únicos
señalados del hecho de violencia que
dejó 10 muertos y 18 heridos en una
reserva indígena de esas cachewan al
norte del país el pasado domingo los
familiares de los fallecidos aún no dan
crédito ha ocurrido
la situación que ocurrió no debería
ocurrirle a nadie en absoluto
me siento observo y Escucho y veo estas
cosas en la televisión
cómo le pasó esto a nuestra familia
porque sucedió no tenemos respuestas
nueve de los fallecidos vivían en la
reserva el décimo era vecino de un
pueblo cercano tres de los heridos
permanecen en estado crítico con los dos
sospechosos muertos queda por resolver
qué motivo a un preso en libertad
condicional y a su hermano a
supuestamente cometer esta matanza esto
es varón el ex asesor del expresidente
de Estados Unidos Donald Trump se
entregó en las últimas horas a las
autoridades de Nueva York banon de 68
años y otros tres hombres habían sido
acusados en agosto de 2020 desdefraudar
a los donantes en una campaña Privada de
recaudación de fondos de 25 millones de
dólares conocida como We will the world
para ayudar a construir el muro
fronterizo con México en la que fue una
de las promesas de campaña estrella de
Trump
terminamos con información de la vuelta
de España porque el
belgarejol reforzó su liderato en la
clasificación general el corredor del
triunfo en la décimo octava etapa que
tuvo un recorrido de 192 kilómetros con
tres puertos de montaña y llegada en uno
de primera categoría en extremadura el
beneples llegó por delante del español
Enrique más su más inmediato perseguidor
en la clasificación general ahora el
ciclista belga está al frente de la
carrera con una renta de dos minutos y 7
segundos sobre el ciclista ibérico el
colombiano Miguel Ángel López ascendió
un puesto en la clasificación general y
ahora es cuarto en la tabla haciendo el
mejor representante de América Latina
Así concluimos esta emisión informativa
nuestra pantalla pero quédense a nuestra
señal y también en nuestro sitio web
France 24.com
[Música]